[Musique]
et pasphrodite a survécu au génocide des
Tutsi en 1994 ces deux frères sont
assassinés à ce quartier de la capitale
rwandaise il tue les gens ici où je me
tiens il y avait des cadavres partout et
ensuite on les jetait dans quel niveau
ici ou sur un charnier là-bas les
habitants du quartier vivent encore dans
l'ombre de ce bâtiment construit par
Félicien Kabuga richissimum d'affaires
accusé par la justice internationale
d'avoir financé et organisé les
massacres et pasphrodite vivaient en
face du bâtiment il échappe aux milices
velocidaire autour qui massacre la
majorité des Tutsi du quartier
après le génocide il intègre ebooka une
organisation de rescapés soutenue par le
gouvernement il se souvient des allées
est venu des miliciens
ce bâtiment là-bas c'était la maison de
Félicien Kabuga où se trouvait le siège
de l'ancien parti au pouvoir le MR nd
les munitions du quartier venaient
prendre leurs armes ici il y avait des
miliciens du Nord ils sortaient quand on
leur donnait l'ordre de partir tués
après plus de 20 ans de cavale Félicien
Kabuga est arrêté en France en 2020 il
est suspecté d'avoir été membre de
l'Akazu un cercle d'extrémiste proche du
président
avant de côtoyer les lignes du pays
Félicien Kabuga fait fortune dans le
commerce du thé du café
au creux des collines de kitchoumi sa
région d'origine ses plantations de thé
sont encore là tout comme ses anciens
employés
un magasin à qui on faisait du commerce
puis il a déménagé à qui gagne pour les
affaires et il est revenu pour acheter
des plantations de thé ici
quand il revenait pour payer les
salaires tout le monde était content
au-dessus des cultures de thé les
vestiges de la fortune de Félicien
Kabuga se trouve encore dans son village
familial mukaranji voici la maison de
Kabuga il vivait ici avant et il venait
pour faire la fête le représentant des
survivants du district Anastase camisi
kunzey avait 20 ans lorsque les
massacres ont commencé
ils te disent qu'il connaissait Kabuga
comme un innocent comme un homme bon
est-ce que c'était un homme d'affaires
mais il ne le connaissait que jusqu'à
ses 30 ans qu'il s'est passé après à
Kigali les gens ici ne savent pas
à l'époque des habitants de guichenbi
écoute la radio libre des Mille Collines
qui encourage les massacres et la haine
contre les Tutsi
un média financé en partie par Félicien
kabuka il était aussi président du
comité d'initiative de la radio il y
avait beaucoup de messages qui disaient
que les outils sont des
ennemis du pays il faut les tuer à c'est
comme ça que beaucoup de général
beaucoup de extrémistes ont été
convaincus qu'ils doivent quand même à
tuer mais en vitesse un peu élevé quoi
ou mémorial du génocide de Kigali plus
de 100000 personnes passent chaque année
devant la liste des investisseurs de la
radio les cartographiciens la troisième
place qui a contribué vraiment à 500 000
c'est une somme vraiment très importante
donc à l'époque pour ses responsabilités
au sein du média extrémiste Kabuga sera
jugé pour incitation à commettre le
génocide
à quelques kilomètres du Mémorial 4000
victimes des massacres reposent dans le
quartier de Nyanza Egide kuranga préside
l'Association des rescapés
de Phéniciens kabuka pour qu'il soit
jugé sur les lieux du crime au Rwanda
plutôt qu'au Pays-Bas
une demande rejetée par le tribunal
était parmi les planiférateurs du
génocide ça veut dire que pendant son
procès il pourra aussi
révéler d'autres informations qui
pourront être utilisés pour d'autres
procès il y en a d'autres qui sont
toujours en liberté que ce soit dans les
pays
européens la France la Belgique mais
aussi dans certains pays en Afrique plus
de 40 mandats et internationaux émis par
le Rwanda à l'encontre de présumés
génocidaire installé en France sont
encore en attente selon les autorités
rwandaises par exemple ce monsieur
ils essaient toujours comme je dis
de fruits de la justice
voilà
pour le gouvernement rwandais le procès
de Félicien qui a bouga est urgent on
aimerait que tous les organisateurs
puissent un jour passer devant la
justice le temps passe c'est donc les
gens vieillissent il y a des
organisateurs qui sont morts on a pris
par après 10 ans 15 ans après et qui ne
sont pas passés devant la justice et ça
c'est pas bien pour l'histoire du pays
c'est pas bien pour les victimes mais
kabuka plaid non coupable même s'il
n'existe pas d'état civil précis
l'accusait à au moins 87 ans ses avocats
ont réclamé l'arrêt des poursuites en
raison de son état de santé